a lot of mormons I think are
uncomfortable actually with Mitt
Romney's bid for the presidency there is
a sense in the church and this goes back
to the 19th century when you know in the
in the 1830s the state of Missouri
issued an extermination order saying
that the Mormons have to be driven out
of the state were all killed this was
given by the governor to the art to the
state militia Joseph Smith was killed
and not vu the the Mormons fled to Utah
than the federal government followed
them there and stamped out polygamy
through arrests and notarial only
families apart and all of that Mormons
are really have a fairly well-developed
sense of persecution in a sense that
people don't really understand them that
the nation might be hostile to them that
they could be again any time made fun of
or attacked or so on and so forth a lot
of mormons feel that mitt romney's
campaign is sort of inviting that so
there are many and warm inches and you
know i wish you weren't running at all i
wish i wish you was not going to be
present now there are others who say
well no this is good because this gives
us a chance to really unpack all of this
stuff and work through all of this
baggage and really become american in a
sense now prove to the country that they
don't have anything to fear from us and
to prove that we are actually fully
american in 1904 a mormon apostle was
elected to the senate and he entered the
senate from the state of utah and there
were three years of hearings over
whether or not the Senate would seek Him
because it was a warm and would he have
divided loyalties right there was this
big brouhaha the Senate debated this for
three years eventually he was confirmed
he took his seat and he turned out to be
an utterly boring middle-of-the-road
Republican senator who helped caused a
great depression that proved to a lot of
people well yeah the Mormons are not
going to try to undermine the Republic
there they're going to be just like
anybody else are going to be boring
Republicans like orrin hatch is today
right but for the Mormons you know there
is still some apprehension about what
mommy's election might mean for
if it would be a good thing or bad thing